all right guys
chess in the 21st century we're going to
be watching a game from what was one of
the strongest events that recently
finished and in which the US did really
good
The Olympian the Olympiad in Baku this
was a game in the match between Russia
and Ukraine and the game is between
Greece Chuck as white and valo Keaton as
black do you guys know who won that
match by the way Ukraine big surprise
they were they were the clear underdog
in this game also valo Keating was more
than 100 points the underdog facing
Greece qu and as black but let's see
what happened in the game so Greece took
open up with f3 a little a little bit of
a background theoretical background they
are both groom felt players you guys
know the groom felt right so the groom
field goes after d4 Knight f6 C 493 and
then d5 both of them very very strong
groom third players top two or editions
so from my experience I'm a groom for
player as well and I hate playing
against the groom felt so I would assume
this is what Greece Chuck also felt and
that's why he tried to kind of avoid
that in the first place so he played
night of three first move Knight of 6 g
3 g6 Bishop g2 Bishop g7 the reti right
a very very flexible flexible opening
that's kind of becoming more and more
common and at top level so here he
played the move c4 c6
what is a what is black kind of aiming
for he's playing - he's aiming to play
d5 whenever white plays d4 also for
example what happens if you just simply
play castle in this position if you play
d4 I'm going to play C 6 and and next
move is going to be d5 but right very
very good so you always have to be
careful in in the opening because you
might be getting tricked if you if you
don't pay a lot of attention Knight c3
not right now supports efore and if you
don't play d5 then I'm going to play for
for example if you play c6 I play me for
and I'm getting something that black
didn't want and that is a King's Indian
structure yeah he didn't want that so
for this reason immediately after c4 he
played the move c6 b3 ok so now let's
try to put ourselves in in blacks shoes
you want to get some sort of groom third
type of structure yeah but the problem
is that white is trying to to play a
certain type of positions and there is
what
yes but more importantly he wants to
keep this pawn we're on d3 most probably
yeah he wants to play Bishop beat Bishop
b2 castle d3 and kind of have this this
type of quiet flexible approach to the
position black obviously try to avoid
that and and and he wants to enter his
main lines in the groom field so yeah
for example if you play if you play
castle I'm simply going to go Bishop g2
Castle and then I'm never going to be
forced to play d4 so this is a victory
for white a moral victory obviously the
game is still going to go on why didn't
achieve any sort of extraordinary
advantage but psychologically I would
assume this is what what white wanted
and black try to avoid at all costs so
after b3 let's try to find a move that
would steer the game into our hands 94
exactly and this is exactly what valo
get in play so once again a very very
small little nuance that if you don't
catch it you might be you might be
facing the type of games that you don't
want to allow your opponent to have so
94 d4 d5 castle castle and this is
exactly what a lot of rueful players
play against the g3 group right they
play c6 d5 and they get this points this
pawn structure similar to what I what
opening Slav obviously so B should be to
Bishop a5
normal moves 92 what would you play in
this position
what could white's idea be
like let's say you play a normal
developing move Knight to d7 did white
have a track in the position
Knight h4 exactly and I think right now
you're going to be losing the bishop
pair by force or you're going to you're
going to give away your Center so after
after Knight h4 and I take 92 Queen
takes D to be shot before doesn't work
because of f3 if you go Bishop f4 f3 and
then you still have to go Bishop at 5
then I think your your Bishop pair and I
have a very nice position and if you go
something like Bishop e6 now I can
simply defend my c4 pawn and next move
is 1 first of all this bishop on e6 is
not very it's not very active and if you
will let me I'll play it for so these
are not the type of positions that black
was what was willing to accept so he
played the different move in this
mission try to create some problems for
for white
what is maybe one of the easiest way to
stop night h4
okay Bishop f6 is an interesting move
but you very rarely going to play it to
play the bishop on g7 is perfectly
placed if you play Bishop h6 for once I
might even be able to I might even be
able to play Knight h4 I'm not sure if
this is exactly what you want because
the dark square bishop is probably your
best piece in the position despite the
fact that you you you you broke my my
structure now I'm actually going to
attack you with h5 and if I manage to
open the center and open this Bishop
then you can probably resign so it's
it's a very dangerous trade you're
making Bishop f6 is not a natural move
usually just is played by natural moves
okay we don't want to protect no please
no thanks okay
see five I think your unfortunately your
you're a little bit behind in
development and I don't think see five
actually works for example if you play
see five I think I can simply take on d5
now if you take with the Queen I think
you might be losing a piece and if you
take on d4 I'm going to take with the
knight c5 it is an interesting idea but
you have to be very careful about the
timing if the if your timing is not
right then it's going to simply be a
blunder no a move that kind of helps
your development as well
Queen to a5 absolutely and this this
Queen a5 is is especially aimed against
the structure with the pond on b3
because now as you see there are a lot
of dark squares on the Queen side that
the screen on a5 is actually going to to
control so yeah Queen a5 is a very
natural very nice continuation for black
III now I have a question for you and if
you if you are at home you can just stop
the video and test yourself it's 93 a
good move
if you said no then you also have to
elaborate a little bit
it does seem like a very appealing move
to be honest because if you take on c3
with the bishop then I simply take back
with the Queen and getting getting your
Bishop er is definitely something that I
would like to do to have the problem
with Knight c3 is is a little bit
different now after Knight c3 does
Quincy one work no because of the for
Kony to write 92 and you lose the Queen
so maybe then what's the only other
option Queen e1 but what's the problem
with Queen e1
all right so just to make it a little
bit more difficult for you guys let's
take it from here because this is where
black has to make the decision whether
he wants to play 93 or not if you if you
play nice III you cannot take it back
let's let's try to calculate 93 Queeny
one Bishop to d3 how is that position is
black winning exactly
Knight to be 192 king h1 we're going to
exchange the Queen's but then your
knight is going to be trapped on it too
so this is the big big problem that you
cannot really miss as black right
because then you're you're almost lost I
mean you can take on f1 but after taking
on c3 you move the Queen I take back on
f1 two pieces for a rook and no other
compensation for that is pretty bad
right so black is I would say
practically losing here and if you play
92 I simply go king each one and after
Queen takes Queen take c1 rook takes you
one this is going to be lost so follow
Keaton being a pretty good tactician he
he didn't fall for 493 he played a
normal developing move Knight d7 Queen
e2
rook to e8 what's the point of rookie
mmm-hmm to play a five in the future
yeah this could all wait if I could
always be an interesting way to simplify
the position and and kind of get rid of
all your opening problems Knight takes
e4 Bishop takes e4 and what is a very
common idea
whenever the bishop on is only four and
we have this fianchettoed Bishop Bishop
to h3 absolutely you're taking basically
you're taking your bishop off the
diagonal and then you're preparing what
move Knight to d2 attacking the e4 the
e4 Bishop you get rid of the of the
light square bishop and then if you
managed to get the bishop perry you're
going to have a very very nice advantage
now this is the critical moment of the
game guys let's let's try to find out
what the candidate moves are and what is
blacks what are blacks best options the
problem with ninety five is that I'm
simply going to play a very natural move
such as rugby one maybe because you're
threatening Bishop d3 right this is the
point now Doug's idea if you take on c5
maybe take on f3 maybe take on b2 so
after night shift yeah the problem with
95 it's not the text e5 one more time
because the takes e5 Bishop takes f3 or
Bishop takes b2 and then you will regain
your peace with dividends but after rook
FD one I'm not really sure where this
night is going so you always have to be
careful you can you can make this type
of nice-looking moves yeah
tricky moves
but you always have to be careful about
very simple defenses so I think after
work everyone maybe black should be
doing quite well yeah or maybe not wait
maybe not what if you just take now you
see you guys shouldn't believe me every
time B takes and now the night has an
objective he's gonna go to a four and
maybe 95 was a brilliancy that is
correct that is correct or let's see
it's definitely a tricky move now the
question is do we have do we have any
alternatives
you know what I'm thinking I'm thinking
where in what position no after detects
if I've just taken a three
okay I think I have an idea try to try
to reinforce your threat of taking on C
591 exactly and in the same time in the
same time you're defending against
Bishop takes d3 Bishop d3 and in the
same time you're also preparing for f3
and catching the bishop so right now if
he goes back to e6 or to a6 well to e6
is actually much worse because if it
goes to e6 than f3 and I think after g4
you might be losing something maybe
maybe not because of Knight g5 so I
don't even have to do that I can just
simply take take and then your pawn is
going to be very weak on on on f5 so 95
very interesting try but 91 probably
refutes it we're going to eliminate that
candidate move what is the most natural
move in the position 9 f6 I go 92 96 I
go and I did 2 and I get what I want I
get the bishop there be 5
the night is hanging the night is
hanging to be honest I think roopd eight
is probably the most natural move but
the problem is that yeah I'm going to
take take 92 and the computer actually
likes black as in he he thinks it's
around equal but I still think white has
the much much more pleasant game so
maybe instead of rook 88 maybe we could
try to find a better alternative Bishop
f5 I'm going to take that guy on f5 and
then you were going to have a bad
structure that's definitely what the e4
square is kind of already yours at least
for the moment but now after Bishop f5
I'm going to take take your your king is
very weak I mean why would you allow
that this is a very symmetrical
structure if you give white the
slightest of advantage he's going to
take he's going to take good care of it
and he's going to be very happy so black
is trying to avoid that at all costs
and you guys already mentioned the right
move one of you I'm not going to say who
fi Vigo 92 and actually I'm threatening
to go f3 to catch your Bishop you might
be in trouble
somebody somebody tell me the the extra
option that we have D take c4 okay you
said it first now he's he said it so yes
that's what I said so why did you guys
eliminate it so fast because of Bishop
takes disable now the question is does
black have any any continuation of their
death
there we go we're starting to go to get
on the right track D take C for Bishop
takes d7 now and it takes is if c4 is
actually the right move I'm not going to
make you calculate the whole thing
because not even Greece Chuck managed to
calculate it so only only the people at
home watching the video can stop the
video and try to calculate everything
but that would be a bit torturous for
you guys so I'm trying to be nice
tonight Bishop takes d7 Queen to h5 now
what are the options nope
you definitely don't have to you have
you have another option which actually
looks like the right one to be honest
no Bishop e8 just loses on the spot
after a Bishop takes f3 and then you
move your queen I go Queen h3 I
checkmate you that's is that enough
material
no definitely not now the two options
are obviously g4 or maybe there's a way
to save the piece King to g2 what's the
problem with Kim G - and for the record
I believe this is what Grisha
kind of missed in the first place when
he allowed two black to play D takes c4
so what's the problem we can't kingi two
guys
rook e to d8 let's say let's assume look
T to DA let's go with the most natural
kind of line yeah rookie to DA what does
white do Bishop goes to h3 right that's
kind of the point of of King G 2 now the
question is does black have a a
continuation there to maybe try to exert
some more pressure on White's position
so King G to rub d8 Bishop to h3 g5 was
actually a pretty nice move
after g4 you have to be a little bit
careful where are you going to put your
your queen paralyze his position to the
maximum where will you keep your Queen
Queen h4 very nice because I think after
Queen h6 if you just play a normal move
like this I can go night King g3 right
and then maybe Bishop g2 and maybe I
managed to escape somehow right
but if you put the Queen on h4 now
there's I simply don't have any any
moves and what is your next move which
one Rock the six rock h6 or
why not age 5 H 5 H times G 4 you're
having a very nice position with with
black so g5 is one way another way is
just simply play rook d6 rook swing to
f6 and then you're having quite some
difficulties defending that f3 Knight so
obviously Greece took understood that
and he played the right move in this
position where which is g4 go on Queen
goes to h3 absolutely
try to find a way to
maybe try to still gain that piece 91 is
an is an interesting question you're
you're posing which is probably which is
what what we should played does that
maintain keeps the peace alive or not
yes what were you thinking
95 maybe right but that allows Quincy to
checkmate right but that's that's a good
good good idea to understand why it's
not good
so night goes to you one Rock d8 I go f3
and maybe I can keep the keep the peace
alive now
well let's see what he did he played
Bishop d3 first did any one of you think
about this move what is the point of it
so he forces you to like exchange and
now you're going to play
option skies options there is more than
one option in this position
there is rook idiot which is kind of the
obvious move but there is also what what
valo kidding played and that is given
the given the match match situation he
is black usually if you if you manage to
make a draw as black especially with a
guy there is a hundred points higher
rated than you are
it's viewed that that result is viewed
as a success so he played rook a to d8
now obviously if if Greece took place
Bishop takes e8 after Quinn takes d4
King h1 Queen f3 this is a draw yeah
perpetual but Greece should decide
decides to take on c6 and plays Bishop
takes c6 now what could do 1 1
difference be having York's you're a
broken d8 another broken from e2 da yes
exactly the break the break in the
center with E 5 is going to be supported
and after Bishop c6 black is going to be
upon down right so what does he need to
look for compensation initiative however
you want to call it some somehow we were
going to try to stop white from
stabilizing the position yeah if white
manages to stabilize the position then
he's simply going to be upon up and
that's going to be problematic for us
but if v is definitely an idea that we
need to keep on the board Bishop takes
c6 B takes c6 Queen goes to e4
and it seems as if white stabilize the
position
how would you continue if you are black
if we five I can I think I can just
simply take rook d2 then I put my bishop
on on c3
it might be okay so he played c5 right
rook a to d1 what now
again try to try to play powerful moves
this is what you need to do to maintain
the initiative if you lose it once again
he's going to be a pawn up and you're
going to have problems equalizing and
this is probably what Greece should kind
of believed he can do but obviously
black has different a different plan in
mind
H 5 GTA 5 GTA 5 wint xh 5 and right now
the after after the disappearance of the
jeep one the white king is always going
to be in trouble right coupled with the
fact that you have some sort of pressure
on the center blacks position is
perfectly fine f4 which is a pretty bad
move and i'm not really sure what what
greece Chuck missed what is one one
problem we have four he's trying to stop
him try trying to stop black from
playing e5 but Queen e2 yeah exactly
Queen to e2
all right what should we do now
what are the options I'm not asking you
to calculate all the way to the end but
maybe give me some options
Bishop III is one the problem with
Bishop III is that I think I'm just
going to take on D for either with the
pawn either with the with the bishop and
I think you might have some problems
after that the bishop on a3 is not
necessarily very well placed knowing
Greece Chuck I would assume he was
already starting to feel that time
pressure his his uh he's a time pressure
addict he actually enjoys it well that's
the question maybe at this point if we
play normal moves we're simply just
going to have a worse position maybe we
have to start looking for ways to to
equalize by force
yeah f5 f5 would have been probably the
best one of the best moves in the
position I think the computer likes
bishop c1 but Bishop c1 just looks so
unnatural to me I would I would never
even consider this move to be honest I
think the point of the computer is
Bishop C once he takes before and then
to go root D - that was the whole point
of Bishop c1 just support root D - but
it's just such an unnatural way of
playing chess that he may agree sugar
didn't even think about it I would
assume f5 would have been very very good
now if you take if you take on b2 after
F takes G six I don't think you can
defend against against Perpetual for
example if you play something like this
rook F one Queen h7 and the game
complicates the game becomes very very
complicated I think white is doing
perfectly fine here okay so this is one
thing that you you guys should be trying
to look for complications whenever you
feel you're being pressured don't give
your opponent an easy game he played
Bishop a1 C takes d4
rook d1
what now
Queen G for Queen g2
what did grease show calculate in this
position what did he calculate and what
did he miss
where is the normal variation in this
position the most forced variation in
this in this position Queen takes G to
go on speak speak louder so Queen takes
you to King take G to D take C 3
well I don't think rule takes III is
actually the the most natural way I
think Bishop g7 king takes g7 rook takes
c3 roopd to look have to draw let's just
put it on the board so that everybody
can see
haha now we're getting somewhere
so this is um this is a draw yeah equal
pawns there's no reason why black would
be better now the question is after
Queen Queen g2 where's the mistake along
that line
what did Greece chicness Queen takes you
to King takes G to D takes e3 Bishop
takes g7 roopd to check exactly and that
internet so that Intermezzo check it
doesn't allow rock have to anymore right
and that's exactly what happened well
that would have happened if great shock
would have chose to take on g7 after
Bishop takes g7 we're now going to take
on g7 we're going to play a route B to
King f3 well or King g3 King takes you
seven and you're going to lose one of
the pawns right
probably not both just one of them is
enough and
rocky - I would would you take on it -
definitely not you you would just
improve the position maybe something
like okay Jade
Black is is almost winning so degree
should play drew key to Bishop takes a
1e5 once again you see why why that rock
only eight is is playing a very very
important role F takes e5 route 65
rookie one King g7 the thing is that
white is not really threatening to take
on it on only on e3 because of Rudy -
King g3
ideas
sometimes simple move simple moves are
enough so he played rocky 8h 3 what's
the problem with this move
Roka five Kingi three
now I think actually rocket rate would
have been would have been quite
difficult for white to to handle because
right now again you cannot take only
three I will take with the rook and then
take on h2 and black is almost winning
if you go King g3 I can even play Raju
six here okay five
lukkage 3 game is over
yeah or very close to very close to
being over so he played h3 with the idea
to or to defend that pawn with maybe you
catch one in the future
f5 King f3
what now be precise
mmm-hmm probably there might be more
than one way of winning this end game
but rocket rate is definitely the most
precise one King g3 what no
exactly j5 rock h2 for king a3 King f6
Roxy one
King at five and grease Chuck being a
nice guy he resigned well I don't know a
nice guy he was probably very annoyed by
the by this moment losing as white on
the Russian team in a team competition
that's terrible
poutine is going to call you and tell
you that you're probably going to be huh
especially against you especially
against Ukraine you you can you can
understand that grease Chuck probably
had a pretty rough night after this game
okay that was just in the 21st century
thank you guys